your faith is very important to you
you've said that publicly your faith is
important Trump has said a lot of things
that aren't true but what does that mean
to the man Donald Trump I was
born into a family where my father was
religious my mother was religious uh I
wouldn't say they were you know going to
church every single day they were you
know they were believers they were very
privately religious such that no one
knew it even me and and strong believers
I went to Sunday school
which was good and which was expected
you know I was like you everybody goes
to start high school right and when you
think about it the world is so different
now anyway so you know you get the just
they slammed Hillary Clinton for
adopting a sort of Southern drawl when
she would speak in front of some
Southern crowds in my mind that's
nothing compared to pretending to be
devoutly religious and against abortion
when clearly you you aren't and you
haven't been your entire life